et ces dames c'est une nouvelle ère qui
commence aujourd'hui parce qu'on va
jouer un nouveau jeu point io dia poids
y aussi le nouveau hangar you le nouveau
slider poètes sont attendus pour yahoo
qui sort chaque jour on a les lunettes
de la classe
une petite bouteille de tropicana le top
25 de norauto ça nous donnera la force
ion d'un viticulteur et le petit tout
droit qui regroupe les fils quand tu vas
d'avoir un nouvel objet électronique
on se mettra autour du doigt en cas
d'extrême urgence à ces partis c'est
l'histoire de ta mère voilà je trouve ça
sonnait bien alors celui-là je vais pas
vous mentir j'ai totalement jamais joué
je ne sais pas du tout quelle est la de
ça ça fait mal
d'accord et si je tue ce truc ça fait
quoi je gagne quelque chose bah non ah
si je gagne d'éleveurs base des level
hockey ruben calme toi tu sais pas visé
[ __ ] et liseron cholet les reds et du
mec sur ce fait sur ce le fait on est
tellement fort mais tire trop vite trop
lui fait mal aux gets the level of the
way c'est cool
ah ok en fait on des points de talent
mais on part dans un délire ok battu et
je craque et tu recommences le v6 alors
qu'ils soient semaine on va se remettre
des dégâts des dégâts et des dégâts pas
se mentir mais tu fais toi d'en devenir
grand pourquoi ils ont tous des doubles
et triples canon mec je comprends pas
royal à l'huile à 28,4 autour de lui il
a trop de fiches mais pas tué mais non
mais non mais ces scandales et aux il
obligera pas je suis que le butin au
[ __ ] battle battlo ouais on va se
faire un cercle fermé des crevettes bon
dieu premièrement au bout de vingt
minutes de jeu [ __ ] qu'est ce que
c'est que ce jeu de merde sera jamais
reçue ce qu'on est mauvais mon gardien
va checker vite ça va nous soulager la
conscience kevin tu es mort kevin
tellement oui tu tires là où en vous
comme ça mais regardez le lui il tire
partout partition guerre va se faire un
mec level 1 million à combat les couches
atteindrait des sommets
y'a pas à temps mais qui lui reste à
faire mais non mais t'es mal et
mauricette maurice étaient connectés
d'accord ma grand-mère ce coup sûr ce
cap ya plus de problème on est
tranquille aya personnes qui veulent
casser les couilles doit être autonome
barwane de cette gamme n'a jamais été
aussi haut level mon gars en bon homme
regrette c'est là en fait se lever le
casting rights watch out ya super vite
alors là on va plus blagues et là mon
gars c'est la fin des blagues c'est la
fin des blacks c'est le début d'une
nouvelle ère oh [ __ ] ça faisait un peu
plus il fait trop mal et alleo le coup
il arrive qu'un
alors je me fais du mouvement de speed
pour aller vraiment très très vite comme
ça on peut chasser les petits et fuir
les grands technique du lâche là là
c'est chaud chez entre tout le monde
mais à quoi donc le canon et
l'insupportable ans le petit thomas usal
a mis le premier tué mon gas ainsi une
série lucie on peut se le faire tant que
les teams locquénin empathie mon gars
oui toi plutôt ici mon grand sa réponse
et on s'arrête plus ben tu toi de faire
exploser bien là l'opac 2,2 à tapas et
maintenant ténors allez je me levais 30
mondial on sera premier de ces quelques
jours on bat les couilles
on est à 3800 le com et la 66 me l'ont
pas découragé ans non non non non c'est
pas ça
mais non mais non au le site il a buggé
nauche lever la norme mais rien tous les
côtés non j'ai pas moi j'veux pas moi je
ne mange pas moi je ne mange pas [ __ ]
je suis choquée sujette à kidder
surprise d'ailleurs qui ne rêverait pas
de jouer [ __ ] de punchlines caen puis
regardez le wet est mort pour couronner
sur un pouf illégal d'armes ont fini sur
wat est mort du roi devant voilà aux
mondieux à lui si on peut se faire aux
petits vins à boire je me bats ma part
je me marre belmeddah mais bel et bien
le match mais calculé je vois pas ce que
va être 13
[ __ ] mais la punition mais quand tu
meurs dans le jeu mais n'ont pas encore
un bug de co mais non oui cette box je
vais je vais tuer cette box un havrais
ça fait vingt fois je dois recommencer à
cause de bugs
jeudi un premier depuis longtemps là
sans déconner l'andam bien ta nou
c'est parti
tu t'es battu et tient cette explosion
nucléaire level 21 on ne s'arrête plus
on est chaud cacao au calme autant
qu'elle me tende l'oreille trente mecs
level 30 bientôt un ssd mauriès au oui
ça y est quoi temps triple choc ou twin
flanqué son problème est quoi tant que
j'aime bien ça tire de partout
ouais mais tu as toi t'es mort toi toi
tu es morte
oui bah oui regardez tir trop vite on
peut rien faire on veut juste mourir ok
je vais mourir je veux mourir je
montréal avait joué que j'ai pris la
pire amélioration du broad quoi ans où
il est 2 les dos effet les tours cet
effet en tirant sur les deux regards des
ouf ouf c'est bourré de 1 à evian
n'attend que bien là bien là bien là est
mort tant que témoin on est dans le
classement mon pote on continue comme ça
on se met bien belle et nato obama great
octo tank alors avec qui tu as à faire
par contre plus on est très nombreux ont
fait mal c'est normal mais je suis un
peu d'ail ok on va s'attaquer au leader
il est là où voyez la petite flèche pour
le prend en chasse il doit pas être loin
c'est lui c'est le leader c'est parti
duel engagé je fuis comme un lâche j'ai
mal moquer technique secrète la bague je
crois mon verre elle promet roues ça
c'est pour nous mais quand il y en a une
immense au maire tout monde et dessus
tomber dessus ils sont fait que les
bâtards casse-toi plan gardes ont fait
la paix ou rio elle est grosse forme
d'un an j'avais vu ça c'est le graal
quoi au nom mais non mais t'es malade
mais tout touriste pam
ok j'ai mis un max de dégâts allez on va
le médoc on va retourner à notre
nouvelle 45
et cette fois acceptée on va tout
défoncer face d'xp c'est parti
ok la spécialisation triple choc ou tout
une flore triple choc c'est pas mal
ouais je vous dis prend que ça en fait
là le truc qui tire des deux côtés
maintenant regardez tu mets de côté a
maintenant il se tourna le premier la
135 milles mais qu'est ce tu veux ça à
mons le mec qui te fait contre un petit
temps comme ça sans déconner il se met
au milieu et il envoie un milliard de
boulet à la seconde doit faire pareil
laisse moi juste celle là stop les mecs
s'il te plaît au tourne autour on se
cache son bail qui lie les dogues se
trouve à la voir c'est nous qui allons
voir les points si on la lega notre vie
va changer attention est ce que la vie
va changer messieurs dames on se le
demande
celles utiles à butten ah non c'est nous
qui l'avons hockey triplé pen a shot
m'apprend le pen à chantôme alors la
mecque
on nous appelle la machine gun là je
pense qu'on va faire le mec du milieu on
peut se faire c'est sur heroes tu vas
arrêter de nous suivre s'il te plaît tu
vas trop naïve jenkins claironne jenkins
allez on s'appelle s'il te plaît s'te
plaît oui la bague et houria rollier
même un peu naruto normalement c'est de
ça marche c'est technique s'te plaît on
boit un peu du tropicana la nature
marche la fais pas le con s'il te plait
il faut toujours garder espoir dans ces
situations
et bah voila voila je déteste je ne
jouais pas à ce jeu point you say il est
nul il est nul qu ai-je dis pas ça parce
que mac os bug des sms que vous appelez
comme mon grand-père le disait un bon
pain fait un bon sandwich c'est
totalement faux c'est juste le slogan de
la boulangerie dont va dissiper papy tu
disais des choses bien comme à la télé
un projet bien de jouer [ __ ] de jeunes
mères voire à melano ça va marcher je
suis désolé cet ado je fais quoi joindre
à la fronde
toi tu cherches tu peux